jake woodford on the mound for st louis
one career appearance against la that
was back in early june
came in to relieve carlos martinez in
the first inning woodford's first start
since july 31st
and betts with a fly ball out to left
o'neal initially broke back under it
makes the catch in the first out
[Applause]
turner rips one down the line and bases
it into the left field corner
trey turner with a two out double
promptly extending his hitting streak to
16 games
blinded to right newt barr is over and
makes the catch sliding to his left
tony godzilla
made his season debut on june 8th
missing the first couple of months with
the shoulder issue
pitched in 10 games in june and july but
went back on the il today makes his
first appearance since late july
the grounder up the middle backhand
justin turner not an easy play but he
got rid of it cleanly and he got edmond
for the first hour 149 hits fourth most
of the national league for goldie
and make it 150.
never seen a basketball you don't like
his
neck high
got him good splitter right there for
out number two
grounded is short for trey turner making
just his second start there is a dodger
flings it across to get him and into
scoreless first for godzilla
and the o2 pitch
swung on and missed strikeout for
woodford his first of the afternoon
the 2-2 pitch
back-to-back strikeouts for jake
woodford
and that'll be a base hit fair inside
that right field line carlson digging
for two the throw by mckinley another
time
andrew is three for 30 with runners in
scoring position this year limited time
playing behind yada yada
andrew on his way to second diving in
head first it's a double and a one
nothing saint louis lead off the bat of
andrew kisner
bounce it a second for mookie betts and
that does it for the cardinals but they
get the first run of the day on a double
from kisner one nothing after two
muncie swats one to left center field
that's down for a two-out hit
bets makes the turn he's at third muncie
the second with a two-out double
and trey turner waiting to come up
turner with 163 hits to lead major
league baseball comes up in a good spot
with runners at second and third and two
down
sharp ground ball base hit tying run is
in muncie stopped it third trey turner
delivers and it's 1-1
a chase
and a strikeout two gone in the third
got him
kind of an unsure swing from carlson on
that back foot breaker to end the inning
just unable to pitch around the lead-off
walk
the 2-2 pitch
and he struck him out
jake woodford with strikeout number
three
drops in to get him
kisner looks at strike three two gone in
the inning
through the left side a big shift and
he's on for the second time today
the 2-2
swag and a miss and he struck him out
so his souvenir skip school
you get to see the dodgers and the
cardinals
and a strikeout what an inning
now o'neill over two cardinals with
three hits in the game the dodgers with
four
and that is hit out to deep left did he
get enough it's at the wall and it is
gone it's a home run
tyler o'neill just over the wall in left
and it's a 2-1 st louis lead as tyler
o'neal pops his 25th home run this year
diving play by justin turner from his
knee gives ornato some of his own
medicine
justin turner with a gem at the hot
corner
the 3-2 pitch he got him strike out of
bellinger
second strikeout
for alex reyes
this payoff pitch to dylan carlson
is by him strike 3-1 gone
out of the payoff to neutral fouled into
the glove and he's got back-to-back cage
to open the ending
got him and alex vestia strikes out the
side in the sixth his tear through the
second half continues
here
comes and the cardinal fans will let him
hear it a standing ovation once again
for albert pujol
same reception every time he's come up
this week although this one may be a
little bit more because this very well
could be his last played appearance here
in saint louis
who tips his batting helmet to the crowd
acknowledging them
and they love it he also acknowledges
the cardinal dugout
on a 3-1 he watches ball four
a pinching walk and moves for the home
pitcher tj mcfarland who walks pujols
[Music]
got him swinging two gone in the seventh
swings at a breaking ball pushes it off
him into short right field where souza
comes on to catch it
and end a score of seventh for joe kelly
six outs for the offense to work with
down to one
so one out and turner hits a fly ball
into left battling the sun o'neal with
the glasses on makes the catch garcia
gets the first uh
man that he faces and out number two
here in the eighth o2 pitch
jammed him slowly hit charging the young
garcia gets the final two outs here at
the top of the eighth
middle of the st louis lineup coming up
in a 2-1 game
quick strikeout of o'neill fort jansen
popped up
left side battling the sun again arenado
he's got it first out
here in the ninth inning
gallegos kicks fires swing at a mess he
struck him out
and it's up now to taylor to extend the
ball game two outs here in the top of
the ninth
3-2 pitch he got him a strikeout to end
it and the cardinals hold on for a 2-1
win
[Applause]